richard nixon and elvis presley i will
hear from former assistant counsel to
president nixon eagle bud crowe and
long-term elvis friend jerry schilling
both of them were at that meeting in
1970. this is live coverage from the
national archives getting underway just
a minute ago missed on tuesday january
12th at noon
columnist and presidential biographer
richard reeves discusses his book daring
young men the heroism and triumph of the
berlin airlift
june 1948 to may 1949.
on thursday january 14th at 7
michael k fonte roy assistant professor
at george mason will moderate a panel
discussion stealth reconstruction the
untold story of southern politics and
history to find out more about these
programs and all of our public programs
and exhibits please refer to our monthly
calendar of events
copies are in the lobby
you'll also find in the lobby brochures
about the national archive other
national archives programs and
activities
another way to get more involved in the
national archives is to become a member
of the foundation of the national
archives the foundation supports the
work of the agency especially its
education and outreach programs and also
in the lobby is information about
foundation membership
now on with tonight's program
39 years ago last month elvis presley
the most famous popular singer of his
time
appeared at the white house gate
he handed the guards a handwritten
letter addressed to the president of the
united states richard nixon asking to
meet with him
the letter was whisked inside the white
house and within hours
the king of rock and roll as presley was
known and the leader of the free world
as all presidents are known
we're meeting in the oval office
the official white house photograph of
richard nixon and elvis presley in the
oval office is one of the most requested
images from the national archives and
you have if you haven't visited our shop
either physically or virtually
i encourage you to do so where you can
buy your own reproduction of that
in paper or on a coffee mug and in
several different formats
that is archives.gov
tonight you'll hear about that famous
meeting from two eyewitnesses our
moderator for the discussion is dr tim
naftali director of the richard nixon
president library and museum in yorba
linda california
dr naphtali came to the archives in 2006
as director of our nixon presidential
materials project
then in 2007 became the director of the
library after it was transferred to the
national archives by a private
foundation
since then dr naftali has overseen the
near completion of an archival edition
and an increase in activity in public
programs in that library
we have released nearly 400 hours of
nixon tapes and more than 200 pages of
nixon textual material he's conducted
126 video oral histories and has nearly
completed the institute installation of
a new exhibit on watergate based on
those oral history accounts and he has
managed the library through two
earthquakes and a major fire
before coming to the archives dr naftali
taught history at several universities
including the university of virginia
there he was also director of the
presidential recordings program at the
miller center of public affairs he
appears frequently in major print and
broadcast media and has authored or
co-authored four books including
khrushchev's cold war the inside story
of an american adversary in his most
recent book
george herbert walker bush
appeared in 2007.
dr naftali holds an undergraduate degree
in history from yale a master's degree
in international economics and johns
hopkins and a master's in
degrees in history from harvard
and now i turn the program off over to
time
thank you david uh david ferrio uh has
been with us a few months and has made a
great change and we're pleased to have
him at the national archives
uh welcome to your belinda it's much
warmer here
actually this is an away game for me and
i'm awfully cold
first of all please join me in welcoming
eagle bud krog and jerry schilling
gentlemen
uh but bud kroge was oh it's do you wait
for the while
bud kroge was deputy to the council to
the president
he oversaw the war on drugs and also
the district of columbia uh he is
perhaps the man most responsible for
getting uh metal detectors into american
airports
sorry about that he is now
seem like a girl i know i know
no it's
it was a good start
and and uh and but it's now associated
with the center for the study of the
presidency and congress
jerry shilling
uh was a close friend
of elvis presley's for 23 years and he
worked for him for 10.
uh he's also a veteran of the music
industry
and you're about to find out
that these men are both superb
raconteurs so we're going to start now
jerry
set this up for us okay because uh
you're you're in los angeles right
you're not working for elvis no okay
it's 1971.
what is elvis doing flying by himself
with a credit card i didn't have a clue
i mean
i was asleep
and i get this call
hey and i go who is this he says it's me
so i knew it was elvis and
i said where are you and he said i'm at
the airport he said um
could you meet me at the at the airport
he was either in dallas i didn't know
where he was
and i said well who's with you elvis
presley always travel with an entourage
and he said nobody and he said i don't
want anybody in the world to know where
i am
and he started giving me his flight
numbers and what time he was coming in
things that elvis presley never did so
that was the start of me picking him up
at lax on a saturday night about
1 30 in the morning
of course uh
the next couple of days were quite
interesting well now
he calls you and uh he he wants you to
pick him up at the airport yes
now how often did elvis travel alone
this was the only time
in the 21 23 years then but this was the
only time in the 20 years
not only not alone but usually you know
five guys at a minimum
you know he's never bought an airline
ticket he's never you know we had to say
elvis it's time you know we got to get
to the airport you know whatever it was
so this was he was on i didn't know what
mission he was on i'm not quite sure if
he knew to the extent
of the mission he was on
but he was on a mission
so
and then you sort of he's also running
away from home a bit he's all he's only
got one cracker
yes and
you know elvis has been known as a quite
generous guy and
after i met him at the airport i found
out the next day
as when i realized late at night almost
early morning that i was the only person
in the world that knew where elvis
presley was i couldn't go to sleep
you know
so elvis goes to sleep and the next day
is sunday and
we get up and we have coffee at his old
home in la it was just two friends
really catching back up
and
in that conversation he had told me he
said you know i really got mad at
graceland and he said you know
people were
telling me how to spend my money he was
buying a lot of gifts i mean
vernon presley and priscilla presley
were only kind of looking out for it
and i think when
when the colonel got involved in it i
was just went whoa i think he got in his
car
he went to the airport he had an
american express credit card
i think he took the first flight out
and he wound up here in d.c
was he carrying guns with him
always
you know but what happened what's this
is
what happened on the plane
um
well as i learned too the next day
when he got to washington
he checked into
the hotel washington and then i don't
think he knew what do i do now
so that's when he called me
went back to the airport went through
dallas and
uh and got in touch with me but he said
what happened is
uh
he he was
really upset about
people telling him how to spend his
money
he i didn't know he had gotten to
washington until
the next day but what happened is when
he changed planes in dallas
he said there was a smart alec little
stewart
with a mustache that came up to me and
said i couldn't imagine this today came
but imagine this today came up to me and
said you can't carry your guns on the
plane
now
seems reasonable
she didn't do anything wrong
now
and all due respect and credibility to
my friend
he did have concealed gun permits he did
he had been collecting badges
uh
he had gotten we had gone to rifle
ranges there had been threats on his
life and we we were
including myself we could carry
concealed weapons
anyway elvis got very upset stormed off
the plane
and the pilot came after him said mr
presley it's okay you can carry your gun
that probably wouldn't happen today
well he only had three
okay so so when did it become clear to
you this is not in los angeles yes you
picked him up that you're gonna go to
washington with him well
uh tim as you said i wasn't working for
elvis i had worked a whole year
at abc television
in a basement after quitting working for
elvis presley
trying to get in as a film editor i was
an apprentice and i just got this job at
paramount studios
and
so
after this nice talk on sunday that
elvis and i had and
he said
there was a brown sunset he goes you
know jerry
i need you to come to washington with me
and i go elvis i can't
i said you know i've worked this whole
year as you know to get into paramount i
got to be at work in the morning
and
you know he was hard to say no to it he
looked like a little boy he goes okay
you know he said first of all he said
i'll get a leer jet and fly you back
well i'm thinking
they were upset with him back there
because he was spending too much money
so so anyway
i go
uh
i said elvis i can't
uh
and then i thought man he had this
incident flying out on on on the
airlines with the guns and
everything and i made a deal with him
i said elvis if you will let me call
graceland
your father and priscilla
and let them know you're not kidnapped
where you are
then i will take the all-nighter flight
and if i could call one of the security
guys there
to meet us where i can go back and
hopefully still have my job
so
that that started the evening of
us
with no money elvis never carried money
taking all night flight from los angeles
here to d.c but didn't you go into the
old house and he took down
from the wall one of his prized gifts or
one of them yeah this was uh this was uh
on hillcrest drive in in beverly hills
and this is where he spent the night
and then and as we're getting ready to
leave
elvis had a little office was very very
cool office and there was a world war
ii commemorative gun it was from
normandy and all these places and
he took it off the wall he didn't give
me a reason i was used to elvis doing
things without explaining him to me you
know so
he takes the gun with him i don't know i
still don't did not know
why we were going to washington
i was just making the arrangements and i
had been so many places with elvis where
i didn't know where i was going so it
was kind of normal for me
and now you ended up with 500 dollars
yeah we i i i talked elvis into uh
letting his normal limousine driver
take us to the airport who he called by
the way sir gerald because he had found
out
years ago i think he was a driver for
winston churchill or something
and elvis was a real history buff i mean
this is the thing he knew he knew his
history and uh
so
it was sunday night we had no cash i i
didn't have any i didn't carry any cash
because i just didn't have any i was
didn't carry any cash because he didn't
have to
so
so anyway
[Music]
sunday night and i had elvis check book
and and sir gerald
found a guy at the beverly hilton hotel
that would cast a check for 500
so i made out the check had elvis sign
it we on the way to the airport we
stopped at the beverly hilton
and i had an envelope with 500
in my coat
and
the brown leather jacket that i wore to
the white house anyway very handsome
outfit by the way thank you thank you i
knew you were impressed i was yeah i'm i
was about as out of my
environment that day as i am tonight so
so anyway uh they pre-board us on the
plane uh for the all-nighter and
it was christmas time and
there were a lot of soldiers coming back
from vietnam
and the ones that
saw elvis there they would say hello he
got into a real conversation with one
soldier for i mean like 10 minutes
and he comes back to me and i'm sitting
the window seat he's here and he goes
where's that money i knew what was going
to happen so
i said what money and he goes
to 500 i said elvis we're going to
washington that's all we've got
he said you don't understand
this man's been in vietnam he's going
back home for christmas to see his
family he gave him the entire 500
so
then you find out about senator murphy
you know um
i'm trying to think how
the
introduction was made uh
i don't know if you know
all i know is senator murphy was on the
plane with us
of course he was in coach we were in
first class
now i'm on government monday now money
i'm on coach now coming here so but uh
anyway uh
we had met
when murphy came on
i don't know if it had been
from the guy who set up the uh meeting
that elvis was having with john finn
later at the bureau of narcotics and and
uh
drugs yeah dangerous drugs
so but when we were on the flight about
halfway through elvis went back and
talked with
senator murphy
and
when he came back he sat down next to me
and i'd never seen elvis presley write a
letter
and he had only written three in his
life at that point that's when he was in
germany in the army
so he said do you think they have any
stationary on the plane i said well you
know let me find out
and i asked the store listen she brought
us some american airlines stationery
so i'm sitting here
elvis is over there he's writing a
letter
you know and i
i respected his privacy i wouldn't look
i didn't say what are you writing a
letter about what's going on
i'm still figuring out how i'm going to
get back to my job without losing it and
he finishes the letter and he goes jerry
would you proofread this for me
and i said yeah and i'm reading this
letter jerry while you while you tell us
that why don't we look at the first page
of that letter oh okay yeah
uh
there's the american airlines station
there it is what was your reaction when
you read this letter
i gotta tell you
um i was pretty i was pretty impressed i
mean
it was
i knew elvis so well and knew where his
heart was
and
there was obviously some
grammar that could have been corrected
but i thought you know what
this is a letter from a guy who
experienced
the real american story from poverty to
being probably the most famous guy in
the world
who was writing a letter from his heart
to his president and i said you know
elvis i think you should send it just as
it is
now
was it clear to you
when when you read it that that that
elvis
wanted to meet the president yeah
because he stated to the side that
that's the first i ever heard of that i
thought we
i didn't know why we were going back to
work
let's look at another page from this
letter and you can explain to us who
john burroughs is
john burroughs is
at one point i don't even know if you
know this tim was a character elvis
played in a movie
uh
and it was an alias
that his manager sometimes used colonel
parker
and
so
now you've got to picture this this is
elvis telling the president
that he's
under an assumed name
incognito and that
to contact him he should contact his
public relations man jerry shilling yeah
so uh
but you know that's that's kind of how
elvis you know that's how he did things
all right so so so what time do you
arrive in washington it was daybreak i
don't know the exact time the red eye
yeah it was a real so what are you going
to do with this letter
well
i you know i'm thinking i
knowing elvis he's not going to put it
in a mailbox you know
so
and i you know i just gave it back to
him and he would tell me what what you
know what he wanted to do when he wanted
to do with it so
um
we i i had called the car from out from
l.a
to meet us i called the limo and i'd
gotten uh sergio gerald to set that up
for us
thank god because we had no money
and um
so it's it's it's actually before
daybreak when we land and
we get in the limo
and
elvis said i want to drop the letter by
the white house and i said elvis
it's it's not even daylight and can
let's just go the hotel i want to
freshen up you know i've been up two
days now
and uh
and he said no no no i i i really wanted
to deliver this i wanted to be there
first thing monday morning which it was
yeah so
we're driving up to the gate but which
gate is it is the northwest gate
northwest i always want to call it the
west wing or something but the northwest
gate
so he said you just stay in the car i
said fine
so
elvis gets out of the limo
and now it's starting to become dawn
what is he wearing you've got to set the
scene for us he's he's wearing a
christian no he's wearing um a kind of
cape coat
he's got a cane actually his hair was a
little longer even than normal for elvis
and
you know for that time of the morning
it was kind of a dracula look yeah
um
so he gets out
and he and the you know the security
guards at the north north east northwest
northwest gate
i see this is not going well
so i jump out of the car and i say
gentlemen please excuse me but this is
mr presley who just wants to drop a
letter off to the president
and they really warmed up and they said
you know
a senator's coming up at seven and uh mr
president will make sure that your
letter is is carried up and
uh to be delivered to the presidency
to the president and so we got in the
car and then we went to hotel washington
but when do you hear about the letter
well
first i just want to say tim that this
is a delight to be here uh today and and
jerry we haven't seen each other for 30
years since that day yeah
[Applause]
when i met jerry and vice versa and and
i will just tell you what happened
because i was i came in a little bit
after the letter arrived because we
started early in that in that white
house and i was sitting at my desk
and i got a call from dwight chapin who
is
the president's scheduling secretary and
who i think we have to acknowledge
tonight as the visionary for putting
this whole thing together that's true
dwight chapin at 7 15 in the morning is
a genius
so he called me up around you know 7 30
7 45 and says bud um the king is here
[Music]
and i looked at the president's schedule
and said what king there aren't the
kings on the schedule here
what are you talking about he said no
not any two-bit king the king the king
of rock elvis presley he's right here
i said dwight come on it's going to be a
long day four days before christmas he
said no i'm reading this letter he said
uh he wants to meet with the president
and um he wants to help on the drug
program and that's what you work on
because one of dwight's jobs was to help
get people in the policy area involved
so he said i'll send the letter over to
you can read it and tell me what what
you think so uh white house messenger
brings it over with a little red tag on
it and i start reading this letter and i
said
no dwight you're really good now
full disclosure requires me to tell you
that i belong to a group of eight guys
who played practical jokes on each other
in the white house every week
and this was my turn to have one played
on me by chapin so i figured okay well
i'll go along with it i'll read this
letter and as as jerry said it towards
the end it said i staying over at the
washington hotel under the name of john
burroughs um would like to see you and
the rest
well
uh i read it i think what do i do with
this well i'm going to try this out so
i called over to the hotel
and with the numbers that you could see
on the screen a private and confidential
or good stuff here that's just
impressive you can only get to me
and i get jerry answers the phone i said
my name is uh bud krogan i have this
letter here from elvis presley i'm
laughing on the phone because i'm
expecting to be talking to dwight's
daughter you know
who's all part of it and he said oh yes
mr progress that does one of the letters
mr presley has written and uh and we
would very much like to see if we could
arrange uh some kind of a meeting with
the president
well i'm still thinking uh all right so
he got a a an impersonator of an aide to
take to take this and this is still
chapin's joke
uh so i said look why don't you come on
over to the white house
and let's talk about this uh because
normally when you're responsible for a
meeting with the president you sort of
like to know who's going to go in uh
into the oval office
so they said oh we'll be right over now
i think maybe a little time of the lapse
from the letters delivery through the
guard at the northwest gate to chapin's
office to me reading it talking it over
with my powers and astounded staff did
you expect to hear from the white house
listen
elvis went to a meeting which he had i
never seen him in a meeting either
and he had left me a phone number and
said you stay here and wait for the
white house call
i read a lot of howard hughes books
where he left people in hotels for like
a year
he ended up staying there himself
so
and i didn't want to hurt elvis's
feelings and tell him we weren't going
to get a call so
that's how that so we were surprised
when when this mr crow called i was
surprised
and
after bud called i never underestimated
my friend's power again
well since you since you mentioned
dwight chapin let's take a look at the
memo that he sent
to bob bob haldeman the president's
chief of staff
this is the memo suggesting uh
offering the option that the president
meet elvis presley the most interesting
part of the memo is page two let's go to
page two do you see the writing you must
be kidding
me
[Laughter]
and and that's that's h that means he
actually said go ahead and that's what
led to
that's right and where he said that he
he wanted the president to start meeting
young people and let's begin with elvis
presley
let's start with the most famous man in
the planet so let's do that and then bob
wrote you must be kidding but you see
his big h there approving the meeting so
so we had a go ahead but now this came a
little bit after
i had had this audition meeting with
jerry and sunny west and one thing you
might tell us a little bit is when did
sunny west join the mini entourage that
came well when uh
when i had made the deal with elvis to
have uh security from memphis meet us
where i could get back to
uh california
when i called elvis who was at
finlayer's office
to tell him
that you wanted to meet about the
meeting with the president
elvis said and this is the type of
friend he was i mean he's going to go
in his mind to the white house it was
the executive offices and you know he
knew if he got that meeting
he knew he was
you know
nobody says no to elvis yeah so i
learned that yeah yeah so
what happened is he said jerry uh go
outside in front of the hotel and i will
swing by and pick you up on the way and
that's you know he included his friends
and everything as i was waiting and i
saw the limousine coming
i saw sonny getting out of a taxi and i
said sonny
put your luggage with the bellman we're
going we're going to the white house
so that's how that's how sunny got
involved so how did the audition go well
the audition went splendidly
i mean i i didn't know until i got a
call from the northwest gate this is now
the old executive office building from
the guard right and i still did not know
you guys were for real uh and and i
thought well it's going to be an
impersonator i still don't know i still
don't know
that's right none of us are free
anyway so this guard said mr korg
there's somebody here who looks
surprisingly like elvis
presley and he's he's wearing an
interesting outfit you know they were
tart type fitting purple velvet pants a
silk shirt open to the navel with the
gold chain and um what do you want me to
do with him sir i said well bring him on
down to the office
they brought him on down it wasn't until
they walked into my office that i
realized oh my goodness this is elvis
presley oh my secretary's oh sandra
greene oh it is it is elvis presley and
then you all came in and i will tell you
that was one of the most lovely half
hours that i've had talking to you all
and hearing elvis talk from the heart
about what his country meant to him uh
he sort of paraphrased the letter i've
gotten a lot from my country yes i want
to give it back i want to help the
country out i can go into any group of
people and be accepted by anyone yes
and he had put in the letter that he
would like to be made a
federal agent at large
we don't have federal agents in line we
got secret service agents fbi we got all
kinds of agents but not agents at large
um but that didn't seem to me to be a
show stopper but i should also
full disclosure requires me to i was the
biggest elvis fan in the 1950s never
went on a date without it you know i
mean so here he is
he's in my office with you guys and
and i'm trying to justify how do i
set this meeting up with the president
because you have to write a script of
talking points yeah and this was sort of
a futile effort but i mean so i'm i'm
talking to him thinking about it what
can i say
and and i think you only stayed about a
half an hour and then i asked you to go
back to the hotel right and i said we'll
see we can get the approvals and this
memo was sent in right after i'd had
that audition dwight had already uh
drafted up a lot of the content and the
reasoning behind by say he's the
visionary for this whole thing so i
called him over i said this meeting has
got to take place the president has
never met anyone quite like elvis
presley elvis hasn't met anyone quite
like the president and what i'm really
saying is and i want to be in this
meeting and i i i
and here's the memo that puts you in the
meeting yes that's good
you see that participants elvis presley
bud group yeah i wrote that does it
actually doesn't say
no
[Applause]
he's a giver he's like the desk no no i
said no i i want to make sure that i
would get in this meeting and and dwight
really wanted to set it up that way so i
i drafted this up and put some ideas
about how elvis could help us on the
drug program because we wanted some
support from the entertainment industry
uh we'd had a number of other
entertainers come back art link letter
and others to help us out because the
government was inherently non-credible
in what it would say about the risks and
the dangers of drugs so we thought this
this would be a helpful thing to do so
and also i think we wanted him to
participate in writing a musical about
getting high on life rather than high on
drugs i mean i i wasn't at my the muse
wasn't probably firing in all cylinders
that that but trying to find ways to
justify so anyway i sent this over and
then got the word back from from dwight
that the meeting was on that alderman
had approved it
and now understand that this is all
going over a two or three hour period
and we've got a lot of people working
hard to see if we can pull this thing
off right and so after i got the word
back from from dwight that bob had
approved it uh the chief of staff and i
think it's probably true today approves
all people that go into the oval office
or we might delegate it to somebody i
called you back at the hotel and i said
the meeting is on uh come on back over
here we're going to have the session
around 11 45 there was a about an hour
period of time when different guests
could come in and we had reserved i
think about five minutes it was going to
be a drop by something like you heard
that term of drop by and take pictures
and the rest well
they came back over
and i got a call from the secret service
uh the head of the secret service
and now remember what jerry said about
taking down this little thing from the
wall
and somehow bringing that across the
country
um
the head of the secret service details
said but we've got a little problem here
i said what's that he said well elvis
has brought a gun with it
it's a very nice gun uh
it's got battles of world war ii
engraved in the barrel and there are
bullets in the display case uh he said
bud you know that no guns in the oval
office is standard policy around here
and i said yeah i realized that and um
so i figured god i wish he told me about
that and in his letter at the bottom of
the letter he said i have a gift for you
which you you can i can give you now or
you can i can give it to you later so
when you can receive it but it would
have been nice to know that he had a gun
but uh but why don't we let's look at
the gun there's a we have a picture of
the gun we have a difficult okay
oh he has to go there isn't that
beautiful
but you can see why the secret service
would wonder you know
he's gonna go on is he gonna take it out
but here's how responsible he was about
the guns when we were driving up
[Music]
to the white that drive that's to me was
to the white house
he took all of his guns off and put them
on the floorboard of the car
except to accept this gift you know
world war ii in a case
there's an interesting thing though i
don't know if you guys know speaking of
the badge the badge he was referring to
he really
he called it a different thing but he
knew the badge that he wanted
a year before elvis was
for years he collected badge but not but
not honorary real badges
and he went to rifle ranges and we had
the right to carry concealed weapons
one night a private detective who had
worked with elvis on a couple of things
set up
one of the few dinners we ever went to
at famous restaurant in beverly hills at
chasen's
he wanted him to meet this guy
who
who worked at disney his name was paul
freeze and he did voices like bo winkle
and stuff
and i'm thinking why would elvis want to
meet this disney voice character
and we go up to a private room we have
dinner
and oh grady the private detective tells
paul freeze
show elvis your badge
paul
reluctantly showed him
his bureau of narcotics and dangerous
drugs
and elvis from that moment on set out to
get that badge
now that would have been helpful
knowledge uh for me
but that badge was the reason he met
with finn later exactly yeah so he
who turned him down
yeah so the first person he meets
turns them down turns itself you know if
the head of the bureau if you can't get
it if you can't get it from from an
agency head you go to the president well
you go to the yeah
you go right up the chain yeah and i'm
on that route to the top of the chain so
anyway i got the the i went across west
executive drive and went over and i i
had to i took the the the gun yes with
the secret service on behalf of the
president by the way this gun is a
featured exhibit in your belinda at the
nixon library you can go see this gun
out there now it's a great guy i didn't
bring it with me it was that's a good
thing
so anyway um we took the gun got past
that and um then we're waiting there in
the roosevelt room for the word from the
secret service to go in and he comes out
and he's mr krog the president is ready
now so we walked into the oval office
and uh uh maybe you have that you might
let's say let's go to the first person
the first oval office picture because he
doesn't just he doesn't just have
the gun no he has his photograph see i i
i wasn't really tumbling to the fact
that he has a lot of photographs in his
left hand and he's got badges the
president is shaking hands with him and
nice to see you i mean just to get elvis
over to the desk it took a little effort
because he walked in the door and he
looked at the eagles engraved in the
ceiling and eagles engraved in the
carpets on the floor and i knew it sort
of overwhelmed him i'm a poor boy from
tupelo mississippi and i'm here in the
oval office of the president of the
united states so i sort of escorted him
yeah i put my hand on his back and moved
him over to
uh to the desk and you can see here that
he's wearing his cool glasses and his
cape and his shirt nobody was ever
dressed quite that way
and the president had never seen anyone
quite like that that either and there's
they're shaking hands and ollie atkins
who is the white house photographer did
a phenomenal job of with these
photographs and maybe what we can do is
the president look like he's kind of
afraid to shake hands he's not quite
sure who he is but
now he's the next let's look at the next
photograph where elvis is showing him
the photo this is this and the little
book i wrote about a while back was
called show-and-tell
he is showing the president pictures of
lisa marie i think priscilla and some of
his badges from all these different uh
departments around the country president
that's beautiful and very nice and
just looking over at me and i said they
are nice pictures now was this part of
the play-by-play that you did well
actually i i'm really going to resign as
a scriptwriter because not one thing
that i put in my talking points were
actually said during the meeting
so but um anyway i'm standing off to the
right a little bit watching this how
many of you have seen the film forrest
gump
okay a lot of you probably a lot of
people watching in c-span uh remember
that line in forrest gump where he's
sitting on the park bench he said my
mama told me that life is like a box of
chocolates you never know what you're
going to get well this was my box of
chocolates moment my forrest gump and
[ __ ] shall we look at forrest gump let's
take a look at forrest gump please
there you go there is
you see all this he's showing cufflinks
that the vice president president
beautiful conflicts really nice
cufflinks there and i'm looking yeah
those are
those are really nice mr president
so then after we are going through uh
show and tell like this and cufflinks
and i'm having a good time and i
actually you can see in my left hand
i've got this pad because you take notes
so that you can write the memoranda of
the meeting afterwards they start
talking about things that elvis has been
studying
and he had put this in his letter too
that i made a study of communist
brainwashing president jeff
and uh
yes and i have really been getting into
that and he's so okay
uh and then he said something about the
beatles that wasn't that flattering he
said you know the beatles came over here
uh made a lot of money and said some
anti-american stuff and president
beatles so the beatles have done that
and and i didn't i'll get right on it mr
president
find out what they're doing you know
it's just and then he talked about how
difficult it was to play las vegas and
the president said yes i understand
that's a that's a hard hard gig to do
out there and go how does he know that
it's just
so this stuff is going back and forth
and and i'm just watching this amazing
conversation unfold
and then as jerry has set this up so
perfectly
the elvis turns to the president and he
said mr president
can you get me a badge from the bureau
of narcotics and dangerous drugs
now i asked this audience if you don't
know the answer to that question what is
the right answer as the staff person
responsible for the meeting what should
i have said
anybody help me here
oh wait no don't get there
yeah
i'll look into it let me check it out
let me find out if it's legal you know i
mean a lot of things that you want to
find out in advance what do you think i
said
mr president if you want to get him a
badge we can get him one
okay exactly so
and so at that point
the president said
get him a badge i want him to have one
elvis is overcome and he steps forward
and he grabs the president
and he hugs him which wasn't the norm in
that white house you know there's you
know
and i'm watching this probably the last
meeting they're going to let me run
around this place
i'm out of here and then after that he
turned to the president and this shows
what jerry was talking about in terms of
elvis's loyalty to his friends
and he turned the president said mr
president do you have time to meet my
friends it would mean a great deal to
them and the president looks at me and
said
but do we have time for that i mean
i mean already we are far beyond
anything anybody thought about this
meeting and i said oh yes sir we do he
said fine so i went out and i think i
brought you guys back in you did there
was a phone call
that the aide that stayed with us
well you took elvis in first
uh and he was explaining to sonny and i
how
you know
it was even above the president it was a
secret service thing and and the phone
rang and he got to call the the
president wants to meet mr presley's
friends now i have to interject one
thing
elvis did like the beatles
oh good yeah this is and bbc will want
to know this yeah
he did
elvis if you look
underlying was trying in his mind
to say everything to president nixon
because the government was after john at
the time and they're sleeping and all
that kind of stuff
he was trying
and he brilliantly did
get the president to re he was relating
to the president on his level he saw
that's why he liked he recorded three of
their records yeah but he loved the
beauty that's right he loved in the book
yes so so anyway then you might go on to
the let's go to the picture the next
picture with when the friends come in
the friends come in
there they are there's your cool leather
jacket isn't that cool which one am i oh
yeah yeah
you're next to elvis between sunny and
sunny is wearing you know his dashing
black tire suit and shirt and he was
just out at the library wasn't he sunny
west just about two or three months ago
yes and you've been invited back i found
that today
to come back so here they're all and
they're talking to each other
we should do it the president's got his
hands on his hips and he said you got a
couple of big ones here elvis you know
hey you know
what when
if i can talk about the first impression
i was i was a history major and i was in
my my last semester i was going to be
practice teaching i was the one student
who got to do that
and
when you took us down to the oval room
if you remember it wasn't a staff guy or
any opened the door it was elvis
and so
pictures are flat right
and all the stuff i'd seen at the white
house when
elvis opened the door and said come on
you know
i looked down and there was the
president at his desk at that point
and i realized the oval room was oval
yeah that was my first and elvis thought
i was afraid which i was intimidated and
he kind of pushed me in
as
and sonny comes in and as we're going
over
the president kind of did a little thing
like that on my show
yeah and goes
uh
looked like some football players it
wasn't not a technical assault it was no
no you know
but i then i realized
there was a human side of president
nixon
well and what was so fun about this part
of it too is that after the president
has met with some guests uh he often
likes the meeting's coming to an end he
wants to give gifts
to the people that have been there now
let's say that you've won
the award for best cow for the 4-h club
in king county washington and you come
to the oval office president will go in
his bottom drawer and give you a golf
ball here's your ball
there's no connection between ball cow
4-h here's your back
it's nice
this is one of the most abiding memories
that i have of this entire episode the
president went behind his desk he opens
the bottom left-hand drawer i wonder if
you could go back to a picture with the
desktop uh can we go back to this okay
see the telephone and uh what is on your
left side the bottom drawer on that side
of the desk is where he had the gifts
and they're arranged by golf balls
through cufflinks to
bracelets to pins and i don't know if
it's an ascending order of value from
the cheapest to the 16 carat gold that
you give to the big hitters
but anyway he's behind his desk starting
to reach down now elvis didn't get to be
the king of rock by not knowing where
the gold is
he went behind the desk with the
president
the kgb can't do this you know but elvis
presley is diving into the president's
drawer and the president's looking at me
and he's cleaning me up he's going back
in
i mean you saw that i remember what he
said remember mr president they have
wives and sweethearts
elvis wasn't clear about what he was
saying there
but i don't remember the sweetheart
maybe it just was and so outcome all
these presents this is four days before
christmas they did all their christmas
shopping in the president's door
and i'm watching this oh there's the
florist over there well looks pretty
good to me
so anyway what did you get by the way i
always wondered what i got i got a set
of cufflinks and then when elvis said
you know they have wives
uh
there was a a gold president uh pennant
for my wife yeah and and i think those
were the 16 karat gold ones that were
towards because elvis could immediately
i mean
we'll get those out there yeah
so anyway um they that you all left
pretty late down you know this was this
was a gift period and we walked across
the oh this is a good picture to show
you going across the oval office we went
out just to the right of that little
cruel work which is the symbol
of the seal of the president of the
united states that julie the president's
daughter had had done for him during the
campaign and gave it to him when nixon
went over the top uh that night when he
was elected it was just to the right of
that you can see that door
and then we went down to lunch
in the um in the mess now the white
house mess is a place that has seen many
famous people movie stars
famous senators even heads of state
would like to be able to eat there
but when i walked in to the white house
mess
with jerry
and sonny west and elvis presley in his
great outfit
people the jaws disrupt
and of course i went over did you hold
his chair to sonny holy i did i i
i i i was so proud of him at that point
he didn't i didn't usually pull out a
chair for elvis but you know and
remember you got the table we didn't
have a it was in the center of the
center of the place yeah that's right
and i saw all this kind of i just i kind
of pulled out the chair and you know he
sat down and sat down yeah and uh do you
remember what you ate god no
[Music]
always a cheeseburger i've been up
almost three days now that's right
so we had a great lunch uh together
and then afterwards now
you have to understand halfway through
this meeting the president and elvis
concluded that it ought to be kept
secret because they weren't sure that
their respective constituencies would
understand why we were all
together yesterday
and so
elvis was saying well you know it's i
think we need to keep this confidential
and president good eye yes that's a good
idea we'll
we'll do that
well um
after lunch uh i called john finn later
over at the bureau of narcotics and
dangerous drugs
and
you know this decision to give
the badge was not my finest hour i just
want you know i just said yes i went
along with it i should have thought it
through but i said uh john uh the
president has decided that he would like
to give an authentic badge
to uh to elvis presley and john finn
later's response was well i guess it's
not so bad to be overruled by the
president
uh he had he had given the correct
answer before right
and so uh he brought a badge over uh
after that that's why we had lunch
because elvis was not going to leave
without him
yeah that's right
got that right
could we could we see that badge
let's look let's take a look at the
badge
there it is
yeah that's a beautiful bed that's the
real
one yeah
so um so he brought that badge over and
um
and you did you did leave with that now
when i said it was secret it was secret
not just for a week it was a secret for
13 months
now here's the way washington works some
people will write memoirs
and somehow those memoirs those drafts
might get into the possession of an
investigative reporter
jack anderson was a very popular you
know how many remember jack anderson oh
you all do there we go around
merry-go-round you turn to that first uh
and there was a story that came out in
january 25th
uh 1970
and i will get uh you can't see this i
don't think we have a slide presley gets
narcotics bureau badge
now now this is not exactly uh a hot
news story this happened a year and a
month earlier but finn later's memoirs
had gotten to jack anderson
and it was like
he got a narcotics badge what's this all
about and i wondered how he got it
that's how he got it from john finn
later and then john finn later's uh uh
memoirs he describes the first meeting
that he had with with elvis and then my
call later on john and i were good
friends and i felt badly about
really making the call but uh not so bad
not so bad right now jerry could you
tell us uh you you've got a bit of a
tour of the white house what did elvis
uh say when he saw the situation
well you know elvis was
a huge film buff and there was a
film called
dr strangelove
and which we used we saw
oh i guess
15 times in our private screenings and
elvis could play every part he could pay
he could play peter sellers choking
himself he could he could do george c
scott well mr president and all that
stuff he was he was he he was a great
actor actually
and
so there's a part in there
where they go in the situation situation
room
and peter sellers
says
you can't fight in the war rooms so we
go in this situation roman elvis says
you can't fight in the war room yeah
that's right
he had a great sense of humor too he did
i think we can see an image of the jack
anderson uh there it is article oh is it
not let's uh maybe we i'm looking at it
but i'm not sure we're looking at it
presley gets narcotics we have
everything at the national archives you
guys are amazing
how did you get that that's amazing
stuff so it and you know when you you
have a meeting like this occur i i
thought all right it's a great meeting
it's arrested secret i didn't say
anything to anybody now imagine this the
king of rock comes to the white house in
the morning and we weren't secreting him
through tunnels or anything like that i
mean we were moving him through the
roosevelt room into the oval office
afterwards we went down the halls and
elvis was friendly with a lot of the
employees the couple kissed a couple of
girls yeah
and um they remembered that and uh and
so
it was something where
to keep that confidential is almost i
mean it's incredible how did how could
that happen top secret material floats
out of that place every day you know but
having this man come in with you and
with sonny and have that be kept secret
for 13 months was incredible and i think
that's what really piqued uh jack
anderson's uh interest absolutely did
you get special bragging rights in the
nixon white house because absolutely you
had met oh and i have just you know i
milked this as much as possible
we still
are yeah that's right that's right 40
years later
[Applause]
you know
of course it's not a lie but through the
magic of video we we can now listen to
president richard nixon
uh remember meeting elvis presley so if
we could play that clip now
um
well it looked good
elvis was clutching some badges from
various police departments and sheriff's
departments around the country then
elvis starts showing the president's
cuff links and presents looking at those
oh those are nice cufflinks well he was
very flamboyant president nixon recalled
the meeting in a 1990 interview i didn't
know that much about him except what i
had read
uh but as i talked to him i sense too
that basically he's a very shy man the
flamboyance was covering up the shutters
people say that because later on it was
found that he had used drugs
that therefore he could not be a good
example they overlooked the fact that he
never used illegal drugs it was always
drugs prescribed by this position but i
think that he was a very sincere
indecent man
you know
you know there's an interesting uh i'll
let you
well you know um it's a there's an
interesting thing and and
you know what what the president said
uh is true actually there's a difference
between
street drugs and prescription drugs you
can certainly abuse
prescription drugs but you know my
observation of this meeting when i i saw
uh the most powerful person
in the world
who
you know
personally politically i was on the
other side at that time
and i saw him meeting the most
popular person in the world and i saw
there was these two great
men
when you think of the world and history
both who were at the had been at the
at the top of their professions but
weren't at that moment
uh
you know elvis was
you
know it
was
okay at the time and the president
wasn't that popular at the time
but my observation of seeing two great
men
connect on a human level and i think
they really
got the loneliness of both of their
positions in the world and it wasn't
just that me they stayed in touch
and
i admired
first of all if there was ever an
american story
that was
elvis presley
we grew up in north memphis poor section
if you ever saw a movie called hustle
and flow that's where elvis and i grew
up and sunny
and
here we were
in the oval room
of the white house with the president of
the united states
and they really had
a human
the president got as you did in the
pre-meeting but
what elvis's intentions were
elvis un he in his own way understood
a certain amount of the pressures of of
of the presidency and it was a real
uh
uh there's so many funny things about
that meeting but the real thing about
that meeting to me if there was ever a
true american story i think that's
one of the top jerry tell a little bit
when when richard nixon went into the
hospital
what elvis did elvis
called him when
the president had phlebitis
and when alphys went in the hospital the
president contacted him
and
there was a really mutual respect and
you know it was nice to know that
a person so powerful as the president of
the united states was a human being yeah
you know i got to you know witness that
personally we
we of course have a clip from president
nixon do you recall elvis presley later
talking to you about
the effect that this visit had on his
life
well you know he was
what he was really proud about
was that
he got the badge yeah
that's right
and
that was his main uh
and he was very particular with this
badge though he wasn't you know like
you know we met on tours and stuff we
had a lot of security and elvis like to
hang out with with the police officers
some became good friends of ours various
parts of the country and he would always
as he did to the president but he would
he had a briefcase of real badges from
different particular who he showed this
badge to he carried it
always
and that's on display at graceland right
now in that long hall of awards yeah
it's up to the wall of gold yeah the
whole wall of gold yeah now we'd like to
open this up to questions yep
so there are mics on left and on the
right
if you have any questions for
jerry or bud
and by the way
i think we have copies
i hope we have enough here of elvis
nixon in the oval office this is the one
that uh that david was referring to and
i think we brought a few hundred of them
are they back there melanie in the back
so if you want to pick this up on the on
the way out this is on a pamphlet that i
wrote a few years ago and the book that
i wrote
the day elvis met nixon 15 years ago is
going to be reprinted by the nixon
library and it should be out the next
few months i think it's a great book it
is really this is the
it has everything in it it's a great
yeah it has very few words which is good
because i don't like it but it's got
lots of the pictures that you've seen
tonight and some more that you that you
haven't seen so that hopefully will be
out but you might want to take this one
because as david said this is one of the
most requested um most requested
photographs yes yeah and but you sell
them right so i win
much better quality yeah
what can i say these are cheapos but you
might have fun with this it's uh
start over there um so of course we all
hear about the white house tapes is
there a tape of this visit and has it
been released no because the taping
system did not start until february of
1971.
a tape this would be a wonderful this
would be the most requested
set of transcripts
in the video clip with the president he
said he only knew about elvis what he
had read and i had heard that he really
didn't know very much about him at all
that can you comment on that sherry how
i think we're fun well you know i think
you know he was very much in in tune
with i think
america americana what was going on he
certainly knew who elvis presley was i
don't know whether he followed the
career completely but he certainly
understood his place
in american culture his importance i
think haldeman understood that i think
obviously dwight chapin who conceived
this whole thing this would not have
happened without dwight's uh foresight
envision uh but i think that the
president was aware of it but i don't
think he played the tunes at night he
played rachmaninoff
love me tender well my few others would
have been good but
sir the question for jerry just wanted
to know if you had any insight or
details of the logistics of elvis
leaving memphis and first his first trip
to washington as far as
you know it just it's mind-boggling to
think that elvis gets on a plane in
memphis
uh comes to washington you know if i was
walking through the airport i'd you know
i'd be standing there probably still
just staring and waiting for elvis to do
or say something but as far as him
arriving in washington and checking into
the hotel
any did he give you any details as far
as anything happening his taxi ride his
you know i just curious if you have any
details on that well there was a couple
of details one one was um
you know
what i'd mentioned earlier about the
flight coming back to meet me and the
gun situation but
there was to tell you what a great actor
elvis was there was a situation where
on that first trip
as the car was taking him
to the hotel
he stopped at a doughnut shop
and
you know elvis
he didn't care where things were it
wasn't in a
a really
good neighborhood and it was
predominantly um
a pretty rough place
as i found out later he was just telling
me stopped at this donut shop and he had
all the jewelry on you know the rings
and
everything and
so
these kind of
superfly guys were going hey man
that's some really nice jewelry you know
he goes in his gun and his boot pulls
out a little
uh snub nose gun and says yeah i aim to
keep it and they all laugh
[Music]
[Laughter]
now
how good an actor he was
uh there's a famous author named peter
geraldnick who is the best music author
he's
searching for robert johnson and
everything and he did last train to
memphis
and as i did 11 years of interviews with
him for these two books um
he kept calling me back and saying
now how were you at the donut shop
when this happened because and he's
i'm and i kept telling him you know
i don't know but you know
and elvis had told that story so much
this was before he came and got me i
thought i was there
you know
so i had you know i had to rescind my
thought about being there
sir
this question is for jerry
uh was the soldier that you guys gave
the money to on the plane was he white
or black
um god you know we didn't really think
in those terms that much actually
um i had heard that i heard
both
you know
i don't really remember and i
it wouldn't i don't know that'd be the
show yeah
the house that it wouldn't have made any
difference then no i wouldn't make any
difference the house that uh elvis met
you at
was that a gift to you from elvis no no
this was his house on hillcrest
uh
i was worth a few million dollars
uh uh he bought me my home in uh 1974 i
live up in the west hollywood hills and
for no reason nobody knew it except the
inner circle and
elvis had knew known that i had lost my
mother when i was like a little over a
year old and
just out of the blue he said you know
you never really had a home i want to be
the one to give it to you that's why i
still live there so
but that's the type of real person he
was thanks sir
uh mr schilling mr crow i'd like to
thank you very much for coming to
washington to tell this story
and you've talked about um in this
meeting we we saw the human side of both
president nixon and elvis presley and i
don't mean this to be a hostile question
but more of a sympathetic one
wasn't richard nixon
a bit of a hypocrite to rail against
drug abuse
when it was alleged that early in his
presidency he was taking
anti-convulsant medication to relieve
stress and i believe it's been well
documented that he was abusing alcohol
uh as the watergate scandal began to
unravel
well i i would i would have to take uh
issue i think with the premise of the
question i don't think that at least to
my knowledge that there was any history
of abuse of alcohol at all i mean and in
terms of the drugs that he used i think
they were all prescribed drugs
i did work on the narcotics programs for
richard nixon for four years
and he focused very
specifically on what he thought were the
most dangerous drugs heroin in
particular
and he shifted the national policy from
a primarily law enforcement policy to
treatment rehabilitation research
education because he saw that as where
we could get the greatest value and it
was done i think because he felt that
was the best policy it would have the
greatest effect but also reduce crime so
i don't see that there was real
hypocrisy i didn't think that it was an
antagonistic question that's a good
question
i just read in the newspaper a few days
ago of a woman who
was working at the white house
and apparently she claims that elvis was
having an affair with her for three
years and that was the reason why he
came to d.c
um
we'd have to ask jack anderson
i have no knowledge i don't know what
happened before he came to l.a
to meet me so i don't know
what his intentions were coming here
originally i don't know but uh
we did have a friend in washington that
we had met in vegas
two sisters and uh that's probably where
that came from because she had worked
with the government as well so
that never got to my office
and he never mentioned that to me and i
you know i spent three days with him i
mean he told me everything that had
happened uh
but i don't you know what i don't
remember
him mentioning that
at all
yeah and this question is for jerry i
understand that ten days after his white
house visit elvis was in washington and
toured the fbi headquarters and wanted
to meet with j edgar hoover who was on
vacation at the time do you know
anything about this did he stay in
washington the whole time did he fly
back to memphis and fly um to washington
again no he after we left he personally
in the car
dropped me off at the airport where i
could get back to my job
and then he and sonny
took a commercial
another commercial flight back to
memphis
i think in his excitement about the
visit and we had a good friend
bill morris
who was the mayor back there and he was
the one that got elvis as one of the 10
outstanding young americans which elvis
mentioned to the president who was one
of those as well
i then elvis and i'm back in l.a but he
did make another trip and brought bill
morris
and a couple of people and uh he did not
meet
hoover it was a lot harder to meet with
jagger hoover than with the president
i i can vouch for that i was awake
so
thank you
sir
i'm just wondering did you get to keep
your job in la
you know and how did how'd the
explanation go
i did i did keep my job in la and there
was no way i was going to tell them the
truth that's right they would have never
believed they would have fired me you
know
so um
i just reported uh i meant to call i was
sick
and
and i worked there for
another
few months and then elvis
uh he liked the way i'd set up things
with you and everybody but
he had told me on the way to the airport
that he wanted me to come back to work
for him and if i did then i could be an
editor on his films
and i didn't answer him and then i get
in the mail business cards
jerry showing personal public relations
to elvis presley
and i thought you know if he wants me to
come back this bad
and i i did love working for him
a few months later i quit paramount and
went back to work for all of us
i don't think there are any other
questions so do you have some final
thoughts well i just like to say that
the story probably is
it doesn't have many redeeming scholarly
literary historical philosophical
importance but it's pure americana that
these two people could come together
and you know given dwight's vision and
the fact that i was a crazy fan of elvis
and and you were terrific in talking to
on the phone and these are just a bunch
of guys trying to to make something
happen and not knowing at the time that
it was really significant i mean this
was just wow look at these two people
together and then watch them as jerry
said relate to each other person to
person and like each other and in the
book you know what we tried to do is
show some of the parallels they came
from absolutely dire poverty and rose to
the pinnacle in their particular
professions and what did it take to do
that i mean the drive and the talent
that elvis had that voice and nixon's
drive and and there
a lot of similarities in the way that
they they lived uh their mansions and
their their gestures you know elvis with
the guitar and nixon you know yeah
this is it just it was just a beautiful
thing to watch and you don't want to
overstate its significance but it's
really part of our country that you can
have somebody like elvis come in and
meet the president and have them relate
to each other in a very positive way and
and be kind to each other yeah and then
i want to follow up i i just i love this
story as you can probably see
yeah
jerry well um
god you know there's so many thoughts
that go on my mind um
i guess to sum it up
to be able to
have a
a friend like elvis presley
i could have never dreamed of as a young
child
and to live in
a country
that something like this could happen
i've been very fortunate and
very proud
to be here at the national archives
it's a wonderful feeling it's almost
intimidating and
i don't think um
an experience in life
uh
these experiences that i i got to have
because of my friend and and certainly
this historical one
life doesn't get much better and thank
you guys for being here too
well i want to i want to thank tom
nastic for organizing this and jeffrey
jackson who's back there and he was the
wizard with all these wonderful images
and of course bud and jerry this has
been a superb evening and as i said
weren't they wonderful rec contours
wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
you